Another milestone in the earthquake recovery
process was celebrated this morning in Kaiapoi,
with the ceremonial handover of regeneration
land ownership from the Crown to Waimakariri
District Council and Te Kōhaka o Tūhaitara
Trust.
The Minister for Greater Christchurch Regeneration,
the Honourable Megan Woods, acknowledged the
importance of the occasion to our local communities.
This is about land going back to local ownership
with communities being fully in power of the
future of what happens in their community
and I think that is something that everyone
in Canterbury will celebrate.
The land divestment will see 70 hectares of
formerly red-zoned residential land in Kaiapoi
moved into the ownership of Council and 5
hectares in The Pines Beach and Kairaki transferred
to the Trust.
This will allow the projects in the Waimakariri
Red Zone Recovery Plan to proceed and the
Minister noted the extensive community involvement
in the plan and praised the resilience of
the local people.
I want to acknowledge the people of Waimakariri,
who have shown over the last 8 years what
is possible as you have journeyed from recovery
to regeneration.
Work has already begun in the regeneration
areas with the community establishment of
a Food Forest and a new roading link in the
east close to completion.
With the recent approval of Regeneration funding
in the Council’s Long Term Plan, most recreational
projects are expected to be completed in the
next two to three years.
We put aside $18 million over several years
for Regeneration areas in Kaiapoi and it’s
all going forward now, along with the work
we’re doing on the riverbank right this very minute.
Other projects include a dog park, BMX track,
sports fields, mahinga kai and heritage areas,
and following today’s ceremony, the next
few years will see exciting progress
for the Waimakariri District.